[Musique]
je m'appelle Peter Parker, je suis presque sûr que vous
savez le reste, j'ai sauvé la ville, je suis tombé
amoureux, puis j'ai sauvé la ville encore et
encore et encore,
regarde, je suis une série de bandes dessinées et je reçois un
album de Noël et c'est tellement  donc popsicle
mais ce n'est plus à propos de moi, plus
Spider-Man se balance une fois par jour zip zap
zop dans son petit masque et ne répond à
personne je t'aime idiots
papa es-tu sérieux
je veux l'entendre papa je t'aime tu dois
copier
mon  je m'appelle Miles Morales, je suis le seul et
unique homme-araignée, du moins c'est pour ça que je
pensais que tu serais là pour le super collisionneur,
tu dois aimer ça comme moi, c'est
impossible, d'
accord, les enfants, écoutez, cette partie est
votre univers détrempé, c'est bizarre, c'est
dégoûtant.  et cette délicieuse frite normale est
mon univers donc tu veux apprendre à être
Spider-Man T apprends-moi oui, je peux avoir le temps de bien me
balancer, fais-le, appuyez deux fois sur la facilité de la tortue et arrêtez-la
à nouveau, fouettez et relâchez
votre arrêt naturel
[Musique]
hé les gars  qui es-tu, je suis Gwen Stacy, je viens
d'une autre, d'une autre dimension, combien
y a-t-il d'autres araignées, hé les gars,
ça ne pourrait littéralement pas devenir plus bizarre,
ça peut devenir bizarre, ok, nous devons
bientôt retourner dans nos univers.
Brooklyn va s'effondrer.  ma famille
vit à Brooklyn whoa
[Musique]
c'est à moi
si je ne détruis pas le collisionneur aucun de
nous n'aura de maison où rentrer à la maison pour
se souvenir de ce qui te rend différent allons-
y,
c'est ce qui fait de toi un officier de Spider-Man
Je t'aime attends
[Musique  ]
de cette façon de cette façon d'une autre manière d'une autre manière d'
une autre manière les
animaux parlent dans cette dimension parce que je
ne veux pas lui faire flipper
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi